[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend mit mir im Studio ist Katja
streso hat später den Sport sehr gerne
schönen guten Abend und wir blicken
gemeinsam auf unsere heutigen
Themen Solidarität mit der Ukraine in
Kiev kommen die EU Außenminister
zusammen erstmals außerhalb des
bündnisgebiets
Medizin Nobelpreis für mRNA Forscher
kottolin corik und Drew Wiseman legten
die Grundlagen für die Entwicklung von
coronaimpfstoffen die letzten Werke
vincent Van gochs eine Ausstellung in
Paris zeigt die Bilder die er in den
Monaten vor seinem Tod gemalt
hat europäische Solidaritätsbekundung
hat die Ukraine schon häufig bekommen
die Geste die aber heute erfolgte will
ein Ausrufezeichen setzen erstmalig
traffen sich die EU Außenminister
außerhalb der Europäischen Union die
Politiker kamen am Morgen in Kiev
zusammen über außergewöhnliche Symbolik
an einem Tag an dem wieder ukrainische
Zivilisten durch russischen Beschuss
starben berichtet jetzt Gunnar
Krüger für ein Foto ist er willkommen im
Kreis der Europäer doch voludomir
selenski will mehr will schnelle
Schritte zur Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine
in der EU
durch die Arbeit auf allen Ebenen
sichern wir die Einheit Europas unserer
gemeinsamen Heimat Europas Einheit ist
ohne die Ukraine unmöglich die EU
Außenminister in Kiev das näht
beitrittshoffnungen davon 27 Ministern
Fehlen der aus Polen das künftig keine
Waffen liefern will und der aus Ungarn
das schon lange Hilfen blockiert das
Treffen legt also auch Riss
frei Hilfe kommen wir in eine kritische
Phase wenn wir jetzt wichtige politische
Zusagen nicht einhalten wichtige
Schritte nicht machen dann kommt ein
Zweifel
auf Zweifel aus den USA wo der
Haushaltsstreit weitere Militärhilfe
blockiert Zweifel aus dem EU-Land
Slowakei wo der russlandfreundliche
Robert fo die Wahlen gewannt Zweifel
ausräumen will die deutsche
Außenministerin und fordert konkrete
Hilfe die Ukraine braucht einen
winterschutzschirm ein
winterschutzschirm der sich aus
Luftverteidigung aber auch aus
Generatoren und einer Stärkung der
Energieversorgung zusammensetzt berbock
besuchte auch Babin bei Kiev gedachte
der Opfer des Massenmords an Juden unter
deutscher Besatzung kein Wort aber eine
Geste die Deutschlands historische
Verantwortung unterstreicht
Anne Brühl ist für uns in Kiev Anne was
bewirkt diese außergewöhnliche Geste der
Solidarität in der
Ukraine natürlich weckt das hier
Hoffnungen denn die Ukraine strebt ja
Richtung Westen Richtung Europa und
annaalena berbock wird hier heute
überall mit ihrem Satz zitiert bald
reiche die EU von Lissabon bis nach
luuchansk das ist aber natürlich
Zukunftsmusik denn VI hier wissen auch
dass diese Mitgliedschaft wahrscheinlich
erst nach dem Ende des kriegsrealität
werden kann und dieser Krieg dieser
russische Angriffskrieg der dauert ja an
die Russen greifen in den letzten Tagen
wieder verstärkt Ziele der Infrastruktur
an die Ukraine hofft natürlich vor allen
Dingen auf mehr militärische
Unterstützung und da gibt es ja bei
mindestens zwei
eu-mgliedstaaten bei Ungarn jetzt auch
der Slowakei größere bedenken was hier
heute wirklich auffällig war war dieses
fast schon demonstrative Bekunden der
Solidarität mit der Ukraine mehr dann
aber auch nicht danke schön nach Kiev
Anne
Brühl morgen ist der Tag der Deutschen
Einheit in diesem Jahr finden die
zentralen feiern in Hamburg statt schon
heute begann das zweitägige Bürgerfest
eröffnet von Bürgermeister chencher der
für mehr Zusammenhalt in der
Gesellschaft war unter dem Horizonte
öffnen bietet die Hansestadt Infostände
Diskussionsveranstaltung und ein
Kulturprogramm Höhepunkt ist dann ein
offizieller Festakt morgen in der
Elbphilharmonie mit
Gästen für eine Doku zum Tag der
Deutschen Einheit konnte ich ein
Interview mit Angela Merkel führen es
ist das erste Fernsehinterview seit Ende
ihrer Kanzlerschaft ich habe erfahren
wer für Sie auch zu Deutschland gehört
wie sie auf den wachsenen Zuspruch für
die AFD blickt und warum sie ihre DDR
Vergangenheit nicht früher schon stärker
betonte ja kommen Sie rein hallo ja
hallo guten Tag hallo da sind Sie ja
schon gleich Frau Merkel guten
tagallo Angela Merkel führt mich durch
ihr Berliner Büro ein Bild der Queen
Schachfiguren cononrad Adenauer und ihr
Wahlkreis in Mecklenburg Vorpommern
fotografiert aus dem Weltall zum ersten
Mal erzählt Merkel warum sie sich erst
zum Ende ihrer Kanzlerschaft zu Ihrer
persönlichen ddrgeschichte äußerte weil
ich mich immer als Kanzlerin aller
deutschen verstanden habe vielleicht
auch manchmal nicht so getraut habe aus
der
ddrzeit frank und frei dauernd zu
sprechen weil das wieder auch so eine
Art Stigmatisierung geworden wäre jetzt
kommt sie wieder mit ihrem
Ostdeutschland vor allem dort in
Ostdeutschland können sich immer mehr
Menschen vorstellen die AFD zu W en
Merkel beobachtet das mit Sorge wenn man
sich sozusagen auf Kosten anderer
Menschen auch anders aussehender
Menschen von Menschen mit anderer
Biografie profiliert dann ist das nichts
wofür ich Verständnis habe da würde ich
immer dagegen argumentieren und würde
sagen man kann in dieser demokratischen
Gesellschaft wirklich auch anders seine
Kritik und seinen Ärger zum Ausdruck
bringen vom Tag der Deutschen Einheit
soll sich jeder angesprochen fühlen der
dauerhaft in Deutschland lebt findet die
Kanzlerin
ad Deutschland umfasst alle ich habe
darüber auch mit dem türkischen
Präsidenten Erdogan sehr häufig
gesprochen wer ist verantwortlich z.B
für türkischstämmige Menschen die hier
zweite dritte Generation wohnen und ich
habe immer gesagt pass auf dass deren
Bundeskanzlerin bin
ich auch wenn sich Merkel zur aktuellen
Politik nicht äußern wollte wird vor
allem beim Thema Integration klar wie
sehr sich der Kurs der CDU nach ihr
verändert hat ja
okayer das Interview mit der Kanzlerin
ad habe ich geführt für die
Dokumentation am Puls wie viel Einheit
haben wir erreicht die morgen nach
unserer 19 Uhr Sendung ausgestrahlt wird
die Doku und das Interview mit Angela
Merkel gibt schon jetzt in voller Länge
in unserer ZDF heute
App tausende niedergelassene Mediziner
und Fachärzte wollten heute ein Zeichen
setzen und ließen ihre Praxen am
Brückentag geschlossen um gegen die
Gesundheitspolitik zu protestieren die
Ärzteverbände werfen dem
Gesundheitsminister vor sich bei
Reformen zu stark auf Kliniken zu
konzentrieren die Zitat schmerzhaften
Sparmaßnahmen zu Lasten der Praxen und
ihrer Patienten müssten zurückgenommen
werden marulin ilau mit
mehr sie legen vor dem
Bundesgesundheitsministerium in Berlin
symbolisch ihre Arztkittel ab es ist
eine Botschaft an Lauterbach er kümmere
sich zu sehr um Krankenhäuser ig um
niedergelassene Haus und Fachärzte ein
bundesweiter Protest gegen die
Sparmaßnahmen der Regierung tausende
Arztpraxen sind heute geschlossen es
gibt noch viele Einzelpraxen und die
Leisten enormes und wenn sie keine
Nachfolger finden dann gehen sie kaputt
es geht hier nicht um Gewinn Maximierung
der Ärzte es geht darum das Ambulante
System der Versorgung unsere Bevölkerung
erhalten zu können es ist einündel
maßnmen
diezte essere Vergütungsstruktur weniger
Bürokratie und Maßnahmen gegen den
Fachkräftemangel der Protest richtet
sich gegen die Gesundheitspolitik der
Bundesregierung der zuständige Minister
zeigt nur zum
teilverständnis ich kann sehr gut
verstehen dass der ärzeschaft zum Teil
mit den Arbeitsbedingungen unzufrieden
ist wir haben zu viel Bürokratie in den
Praxen wir haben auch zu wenige Ärzte
die Honorarforderungen da bin ich nicht
der Meinung dass es das Hauptproblem ist
die Honorare werden jetzt nach dem
Abschluss der kassenchen Vereinigungen
der neu um 4% steigen 5000 zusätzliche
Medizinstudienplätze verspricht der
Minister doch das wird nicht reichen
sagen Ärzte Vertreter der Kipppunkt sei
schon jetzt erreicht wenn die alle
keinen Nachfolger finden die jetzt die
Praxis abgeben dann ist die Versorung
wie wir sie kennen vorbei also wir
brauchen tatsächlich hier einen sehr
sehr schnellen Schwenk in der
Gesundheitspolitik die Praxen am Limit
zu viele Patienten zu wenig Ärzte und
immer mehr praxisschließungen und bis
neue Medizinstudenten aktiv werden
können das wird
dauern der Nobelpreis für Medizin geht
an zwei Forscher deren Arbeit
entscheidend war für die modernen mRNA
Impfstoffe zur Bekämpfung der
coronapandemie und es gibt eine enge
Verbindung nach Deutschland die heute
ausgezeichnete Biochemikerin kottolin
coriko aus Ungarn war viele Jahre beim
meainster Unternehmen biontech
angestellt sie erhält den Preis
gemeinsam mit dem us-immunologen Drew
Wiseman Lena sünderbruch
bahnbrechende Forschung zur
Impfstoffentwicklung attestiert das
Nobelkomitee kotolin corico und Drew
weisem die gebürtige Ungarin und der
US-Amerikaner forschen seit über 20
Jahren zusammen an der University of
Pennsylvania die Auszeichnung jetzt ist
mehr als nur eine große Freude für
coriko es geht darum für die
Wissenschaft zu werben und jungen
Menschen die Schönheit der Wissenschaft
die große Freude an der Forschung
bewusst zuachchen und sie darauf
vorzubereiten dass Ergebnis nicht sofort
kommmen sondern dass man dafür arbeiten
muss 2005 gelingt corico und weseman der
Durchbruch sie finden heraus wie man
fremde mRNA in den Körper einsetzen kann
die mRNA überträgt Informationen für die
Produktion von Antigenen an unsere
Zellen der Körper stellt dann nach
diesem Vorbild Proteine her und löst die
gewünschte Immunreaktion
aus so werden die beiden Preisträger zu
Wegbereitern der coronaimpfstoffe
während der Pandemie ist corico
Vizepräsidentin von biontech doch die
mRNA Forschung verspricht noch viel mehr
als das das kann man jetzt aber auch
anwenden z.B für grippeimpstoffe für
neue HIV Impfstoffe für Hepatitis
Impfstoffe die wir noch nicht haben und
vielleicht noch wichtiger um unser
Immunsystem gegen Tumoren gegen Krebs zu
stimulieren damit es den einfach
eindämmt und idealerweise sogar aus dem
Körper wieder raustreibt die mRNA
Technologie mit corikos und wesemans
Beitrag zur Grundlagenforschung sind
große Hoffnungen für die Zukunft
verbunden fast zwei Wochen ist das jetzt
her da Zwang Aserbaidschan mit heftigen
Angriffen Bergkarabach zur Aufgabe
international war die selbsternannte
Republik auf dem Staatsgebiet
Aserbaidschans nie anerkannt aber dort
lebten fast nur ethnische Armenier von
120.000 Einwohnern sind seit der
Kapitulation 100.000 Richtung Westen
nach Armenien geflohen unser Reporter
sebastian
ist gerade in der Region unterwegs unter
Aufsicht aserbaidschanischer offizieller
sein Bericht beginnt in stepaner
kert es ist der dritte Checkpoint den
wir passieren müssen bis wir in der
Stadt sind die vor wenigen Tagen einen
Massenexodus erlebte stepana keht
ehemals das lebhafte Zentrum Berg
cararabachs ist jetzt eine
Geisterstadt wir fahren gerade durch die
ehemalig Hauptstadt der Republik
Bergkarabach Stepanakert oder wie die
Aserbaidschaner sagenankend wir erleben
eine Stadt die fast komplett verlassen
ist obwohl hier eigentlich laut
Gerüchten noch Armenier leben sollen
aussteigen dürfen wir aber nicht das
haben die Sicherheitskräfte verboten aus
Sicherheitsgründen wie es heißt am
Straßenrand ausgeschlachtete Autos die
Häuser verlassen ein ausgebleichtes
Plakat von Wladimir Putin wie ein Symbol
D die einzige Schutzmacht die Bewohner
nicht gerettet hat wir gern ob noch
Armenier in der Stadt sind und wenn ja
wie es Ihnen geht aber die
aserbaidschanischen Behörden haben
andere Pläne mit uns am ehemaligen
Flughafen bergkarabachs findet ein
Pressetermin statt aserbeidschanischen
und internationalen Journalisten wird
eine Hanfplantage
vorgeführt das ist einer der ersten
großen Beweise dass hier in den früher
besetzten Gebieten eine sehr gut
organisierte Drogenproduktion und
Drogenhandel stattgefunden hat
die aserbaidschanischen Behörden wollten
mit diesem Termin heute vor allem eins
erreichen die karabacharmenia zu
kriminalisieren und damit auch das
eigene Vorgehen in Bergkarabach weiter
zu
rechtfertigen es scheint als wolle man
ablenken von armenischer Flucht und dem
Leid der
Menschen gegen
exus-präsident Trump laufen mehrere
verfahr heute ging es in einem
Zivilprozess um Betrug zum Auftakt
erschien Trump persönlich vor dem
Gericht in New York die
Staatsanwaltschaft wirft ihm unter
anderem vor seine Vermögenswerte
aufgeblätt zu haben um günstigere
Kredite zu bekommen im Falle einer
Verurteilung droht ihm ein Bußgeld in
Millionenhöhe zum tödlichen Brand in
Spanien gestern jetzt wurde bekannt dass
dem Nachtclub schon Anfang letzten
Jahres die Betriebsgenehmigung entzogen
wurde offenbar wegen unerlaubter
Umbauarbeiten mit einer Schweigeminute
gedachten Politiker und
Behördenvertreter der 13 Todesopfer am
frühen Sonntag Morgen war das Feuer in
mursia im Südosten des Landes
ausgebrochen warum ist noch völlig
unklar im raserprozess von MS hat das
Landgericht Duisburg einen Mann zu 5
Jahren Haft verurteilt bei dem illegalen
Autorennen starb im April 2019 eine
unbeteiligte Frau zum dritten Mal stand
der Fahrer vor Gericht nachdem der
Bundesgerichtshof das Urteil bereits
zweimal aufgehoben hatte der damals
2-jährige war beim Rennen mit einem
Bekannten mit fast 170 stundenkilomet
durch ein Wohngebiet gerast und dann mit
dem Auto der 43-jährigen Frau
kollidiert
Weizenfeld mit Kre dieses Gemälde von
Vincent van Goch sehen manche als seinen
visuellen Abschiedsbrief und lesen die
schwarzen Vögel als Todesboten
entstanden ist es im Juli 1890 kurz vor
seinem Tod eine Ausstellung im müsee
Dors in Paris zeigt Meisterwerke aus van
gochs letzten Lebenswochen in den er
noch mal einen warahren Schaffensrausch
erlebte Anne
Arend das Landleben vor den Toren von
Paris eingefangen in den Bilderwelten
von Vincent van Goch unermütlich
besessen streift der Künstler durch
einem kleinen Ort am Fluss was das moch
widmet sich nun diesen letzten Wochen
vor seinem
Tod bei seiner Ankunft dort ist er noch
sehr enthusiastisch glaubt plötzlich von
allen Krankheiten geheilt zu sein das
neue Umfeld die Veränderung die
Schönheit inspirieren ihn doch dann
kehren die Probleme zurück die Sorgen
die
Unruhe von Mai bis Juli 1890 wohnt van
Goch in dieser Herberge trifft dort auch
andere Künstler die zu jener gerne aufs
Land reisen van Gors Kammer unterm Dach
ist nach seinem Selbstmord nie wieder
vermietet worden darin darf nicht
gefilmt doch sie kann besichtigt werden
und sie zieht wie
und seine Umgebung viele Besucher an die
das Leben und die Gedanken des Künstlers
mit seinen Werken in Deckung bringen
wollen das Weizenfeld mit Krähen etwa
verwandelt in eine dramatisch anmutende
Landschaft und die Wurzeln die letzten
Pinselstriche wenige Stunden vor seinem
Tod bezeichnen für diese Bilder ist das
breite
Format das ermöglichte ihm seine Gefühle
den Moment auf eine neue Art zu
vermitteln gedrückt verängstigt von
beiden Seiten
auseinandergerissen kurz doch intensiv
ist die Zeit aus der das M doch seh nun
40 Gemälde und 20 Zeichnungen zeigt
kraftvoll und melancholisch
wie der
künstlerch jetzt kom wir zu einem ganz
anderen Künstler beim Sport zu einem
wirklich erfolgreichen deutschen
Tennisprofi und der heißt Alexander S
und der steht im Halbfinale des ATP
Turniers in chinas Hauptstadt Peking der
26-Jährige Hamburger besiegte den
Chilenen ncolas Jari in drei Sätzen
dabei war es für SF kein einfacher Tag
denn bei ihm lag doch einiges im
agen heren laufende Nase der
bioryhythmus aus dem Takt und trotzdem
Alexander zwerev siegt und steht im
Halbfinale gegen Nicolas Jarry unten
gelingt der siebte Sieg in Folge auf der
Asientour der erste Satz geht mit 6:1 an
den Hamburger den zweiten muss er im
Tiebreak abgeben an den Chilenen zwerf
über die komplette Distanz aber
aufschlagstark überragende 85% der
ersten Aufschläge im Feld insgesamt
schlägt er 13 Asse Matchball und ass zum
Dreisatzsieg zwer sammelt weiter
qualipunkte fürs ATP
Saisonfinale ihr hört ja ich bin ein
bisschen krank aber es hat ja einen
Grund dass ich hier bin ich habe ein
Ziel die Einstellung und ich will
gewinnen zwerf trifft jetzt in China auf
einen alten Bekannten den Russen Daniel
medwedev zur Fußball buundesliga in der
sich der SC Freiburg im abendlichen
Sonntagsspiel über einen Sieg freuen
durfte 2:0 gegen den FC Augsburg an
beiden Toren beteiligt vinceno Grifo als
Torschütze zum 1:0 per 11 Meter und dann
als Vorbereiter sein eckb landet auf dem
Kopf von Philip Lenhard das 2:0 gibt
vielleicht auch Rückenwind für das
Europa League Spiel dann am Donnerstag
gegen West Ham
United und alle Spiele und Tore des
Bundesliga Wochenendes finden Sie wie
immer unter zfheute.de oder in der
zdfheute App und noch dies Deutschlands
Volleyballer wollen nach Paris zu den
Olympischen Spielen und können sich
dafür ganz aktuell beim Turnier in Rio
de Janeiro Brasilien qualifizieren im
zweiten Spiel schaffen sie jetzt ihren
zweiten Sieg ein 3:1 gegen Kuba in der
acht nationengruppe muss Deutschland
mindestens Zweiter werden dann geht's im
kommenden Jahr zu Olympia aber die
schwierigen Brocken die kommen erst noch
Mittwoch z.B Brasilien danke schön Katja
dankees schönen ja heute war es warm
morgen stürmisch und regnerisch
Einzelheiten hat gleich Katja horneffer
Außenministerin bärbock ab
21:45 Uhr im heute journal interterview
mit Marietta Slomka einen entspannten
Abend und morgen einen schönen Feiertag
für sie da sind wir dann auch wieder für
Sie da
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend nach dem
rekordwarmen september macht der Oktober
gleich mal so weiter in nordrinwestfalen
in Weilerswist Lommersum lagen heute die
Höchsttemperaturen bei
29,4° das war noch nie so warm Anfang
Oktober seit 44 Jahren jetzt aber ändert
sich was das liegt an einer Kaltfront
und die sehen Sie hier schon über dem
Atlantik und über Großbritannien
heranrauschen und die ersten Wolken
machen sich schon heute Nacht bemerkbar
so kann es in Schleswig-Holstein zum
frühen Morgen auch schon den ersten
Regen geben sonst ist es häufig noch
klar und es bildet sich Nebel das wird
eine sehr milde Herbstnacht mit
tiefstemperaturen zwischen 17 und 8° und
morgen merken wir dann schon dass eine
Kaltfront herangezogen ist denn die
Höchsttemperaturen im Westen liegen dann
nur noch so bei 20 21° im südlichen
Brandenburg in Sachsen und in Bayern
werden noch mal bis zu 29° erreicht am
Vormittag kommt die Kaltfront hier im
Nordwesten an und bis zum Abend weitet
sie sich dann Richtung Osten aus
erreicht oder und nece das sind kräftige
Schauer und Gewitter dabei und es wird
sehr stürmisch uns erwarten schwere
sturmböhen z.B im Thüringerwald und dem
Erz ge da werden Äste abgerissen und
ganze Bäume umstürzen deutlich ruhiger
geht es dann Ende der Woche weiter bei
Höchsttemperaturen von 17 bis 23° am
Freitag guten Abend